comme un air de 2012 le premier tour de
cette législative partielle remet au
goût du jour le clivage gauche droite
dans la 11e circonscription c'est le
candidat de la droite qui vire en tête
philippe benassaya recueillent 36% des
suffrages
on peut regretter bien sûr l'abstention
la faible participation
c'est une législative partielle qui
tombe à si mal je vais continuer dans ce
sens ce entre deux tours ma présence sur
le terrain on sort d'un épisode quand
même un peu malheureux sur cette 11e
circonscription
je voudrais redonner une image de
terrain et une image assez proche de nos
concitoyens et c'est important d'envoyer
à l'assemblée nationale des élus locaux
les acteurs locaux qu'ils sachent gérer
des projets et et qui ont fait leurs
preuves et qui ont obtenu des résultats
face au maire de bois d'arcy sandrine
grand gang la première adjointe de la
ville de trappes obtient près de 25%
candidats beaucoup d'attention pas
beaucoup de litiges moi ce que pouvait
être le résultat
et puis des basques rattrape mais aussi
pour donc éléments de cette exception
les messages pas qu'on a commencé à
envoyer ont été entendus le parti
présidentiel lui ne confirme pas le
scrutin de 2010 est remporté par nadia
et pierre luc le candidat lrm n'est pas
qualifié pour le second tour
le délégué départemental ne récolte que
15% des suffrages séparent attribué le
résultat uniquement à l'action ou
l'inaction de gouvernement ou de
mouvements serait peut-être un peu
égocentrique je pense qu'il faut
regarder aussi du côté des campagnes
quelques minutes par les docks milla est
évidemment s'interroger sur eux pour le
projet et les mal an environ
arrivé en quatrième position le
rassemblement national obtient 7% un
score similaire au scrutin de 2010 est
nous l'avons vu au moment des
municipales une électorat est beaucoup
plus rétifs à se déplacer aux urnes
demain
de par le contexte sanitaire donc
finalement nous savions que cette
élection est très difficile pour nous
sur ce territoire là mais finalement
nous sommes dans les niveaux qu'on
pourrait apprendre un scrutin marqué par
l'abstention seulement 17% des ans
se sont déplacés dans les bureaux de
vote le second tour est prévu dimanche
27 septembre